uh how are you doing today sir
sick of [ __ ] man
for real
yeah i got sick last night i don't know
my head's
brutal
i am very sorry that sucks especially
especially since you know it's not like
you're filming a big movie right now
i know tomorrow i gotta call work and
going guys
uh
i apologize i'm just going to jump in
because i have such a little limited
time with you um i do hope you feel
sincerely better sincere like i i really
mean that um
uh i spoke to a little bit ago and you
told me
for sweet girl and you told me at the
end of the interview you're gonna go see
dune that day i was riddled with envy
uh the movie's amazing uh uh but i am
curious what is it like being part of a
movie like this and watching it can you
experience it like a normal movie like
what is it like for you
actually watching something like this
when you're a part of it
i i 100 percent dove into this like a
like it was i wasn't in it
i feel like
um
that when i went to go see it that was
the third time i saw it
and it was
so good
i mean
i was blown away the first time i saw it
was blown away the second time i went to
my kids which was really really crazy to
like i've never taken them to something
that's that adult yet
but i knew it was very important there's
a lot of things i did for my son in that
film like if i'm doing these things to
timothy like he learned kali so i used
that for the film and there's just a lot
of like intimate moments for for my kids
and so i wanted to show them
and it
it gutted me because when it what
happens in the film
you know my kids are seeing that for the
first time i'm like oh god it's that
same time i wanted to see it it's her
favorite movie so now they're like
they're 100 percent love dune
um
yeah bro i i'm excited to see the rest
of it you know i mean like when i seen
listen i i need with all my heart and
soul i need to need to be able to make
his trilogy because the movie is so
amazing i'm just i need it it's like one
of the first and you know what i mean a
bro it's it's killing me that we have to
wait a year and it's telling me that
they're not in production yet i'm like
guys
we gotta go
i i completely agree um what do you when
did you realize when you were making the
film that you were actually a part of
something that was going to be very
special
i mean the moment he called me i mean he
called me
and chose me i've had an audition my
whole life to get something i just
couldn't believe that
he before he got the script he sent me
his like bible of like what the whole
movie is and images and
i've never been chosen for anything
especially to be you know he's wanted to
do it his whole life
so it's his
masterpiece his life goal
and then you know having him look at me
and see me as duncan idaho is just
crazy
uh i love that um all the women in this
movie and in the book are all so
powerful and uh and it was written in
the 60s which is really unusual for you
um it's like it feels very the story
back then was very modern to today can
you sort of talk about the fact that
this this movie has so many strong women
in it
yeah i mean uh charlotte ranking
ramplings steals the movie i mean like i
was blown away when i saw the
performances obviously i wasn't part of
any of that
she
she was better in that scene than
anything i've ever done in my
performance in anything i've ever done i
was blown away rebecca ferguson is just
such a talent totally opposite of that
character i mean she's just she's
wonderful so i i don't know i i got like
a master's class in acting and that's
just i mean
from the women
to the men the whole thing is just like
i was i felt like
i shouldn't be here right now how the
hell did i get in here
so it was an honor man
uh i gotta go but i'm gonna say dude
you're pretty talented i think you're
selling yourself really short right now
you know what i mean i sincerely i i
hope you feel a lot better and uh thank
you for giving me your time and man the
movie's amazing thanks for being
understanding bro thank you cheers man
later